today I want to talk about how to create
a daily schedule hey guys welcome to
another book update video I am with the
big camera and Jason today instead of on
my iPad as usual because yesterday I
didn't have time to go out and do my
book writing because I'm in the process
of acquiring a new business and the
lawyers and accountants could only meet
yesterday and so I was not able to get
my book writing done and that led to
some concerns and some issues about my
schedule and I thought it'd be helpful
for you guys to understand how I create
my schedule and maybe you could learn
from that process increases them that
serves you as well I'm a big believer in
setting yourself up for success and in
creating a daily and weekly schedule
that encompasses all of the things that
you want to have accomplished it's easy
to have big goals and big dreams but if
you don't allow time for those things
that happen in every week then you're
not going to go out and accomplish them
and your to-do lists will just keep
growing and growing and growing and so
how I approach it is one I like to have
a morning routine that sets me up for
success and I've you know this whole
process now has gotten me to to rethink
what is my daily schedule so my mornings
now I've switched up so I'm waking up
with my wife she wakes up earlier than I
do
she used to now I wake up with her and I
make her some breakfast and lunch for
her to take to work she has a normal
regular job and it's nice being able to
start the day and give her a hug and see
her off to her work when she leaves I'll
then do a quick meditation then after
that I'll do a quick run usually
watching some YouTube videos get some
energy and some excitement then after
that quick shower stretch and I'm ready
for work I'm trying to start my day my
official work day the same Monday
through Friday and we'll see how that
works out but it's going to start with
me reviewing the videos that have to go
up on my channel and then also
responding to some of the comments I've
dedicated the time every day to will
respond to your comments because there's
a lot to come in and I know Nina's doing
a lot but I try to help too I'm also
answering emails from my team and that's
how I'm going to start my morning
everyday in my business side from there
on what happens for the rest of the late
morning early afternoon late afternoon
every day is a different day and I find
that that helps me
stay structured stay organized and get
stuff done and so for you guys watching
I would recommend thinking but what are
the big goals that you have what are the
big projects that you're working on and
then assigning them to different days so
Monday used to be mine midday I'm moving
that to my new company day doing all the
stuff that need to get done for the new
company Tuesday is still going to be my
book writing day Wednesday is still
going to be my video recording day
Thursday is still going to be my
public-facing meetings day calls radio
interviews Google Hangouts and Friday
I'm moving to become kind of like my day
important projects they get stuff done
for the next week so I used to start off
my week doing everything I need to get
done for the week now I'm going to close
my week get anything done for the next
week I will see how that goes the
schedule is always a work in progress
anytime something new was introduced
into the mix then that causes my
schedule to want to change and whether
you build it like me or you do it at a
different way the important thing is
that when you're creating the schedule
it has all of your big goals in mind so
that you're making sure that you're
spending time on everything right that
that dream that you have there's time in
your calendar every single day or every
single week to make sure that you move
forward on your dreams so get into your
questions there are only two questions
this week because I didn't ask you guys
for questions last week and the two are
not related to the book so the first one
was from Lee Garfield Evan these videos
are my favorite walking and talking with
your iPad through the Canadian suburbs
Thank You Lee I appreciate that I'm not
really in the suburbs Jason we in the
suburbs is the suburbs it is you think
this is suburbs really wow that's hard
core I feel like Mississauga suburbs or
something we're in North York is an city
alright well maybe we are in the suburbs
but it's not downtown I guess who's your
thing so I thank you I appreciate that
and the next one is from press app this
is awesome stuff always loved the
content thank you Evan I don't know
whether you'll be interested in this but
just wanted to check I know you like
Fitness I wanted to know whether we can
do a hangout session on Fitness natural
bodybuilding I believe we can come up
with a great content I know I'm a small
time youtuber let me know I don't know
if you noticed I am not necessarily the
biggest bodybuilder ah but
open for potential collab let me know
and let's figure it out so for those of
you watching I want some more questions
ideally related to setting the schedule
or something related to the book writing
process your book writing process your
questions about writing the book
questions about my book because that's
what this series is supposed to be about
right in the book so thank you guys so
much for watching next week back to the
iPad and I got to get back to editing my
book I'm super excited I've already done
two chapters of the book and how many
chapters are there ten something like
that so 20% of the way through on the
editing I'm pretty excited about it
and I'll keep you guys posted pre share
all the love appreciate all the support
make sure you ask the question and I'll
see you soon